POLICEMEN VISIBLE ON THE STREETS
DURING THAT PERIOD YOU ARE
DRIVING AROUND THE SOUTH SIDE.
MY FELLOW FOX NEWS PRIME TIME
HOST, TAMMY BRUCE IS HERE.
TAMMY, THIS IS A TERRIBLE
SUBJECT TO BE TALKING ABOUT ON
AN INDEPENDENCE DAY WEEKEND.
IT SHOULD SURELY SHAME -- I
DON'T WANT TO BE POLITICAL ABOUT
IT, BUT THESE CITIES HAVE BEEN
DEMOCRAT CITIES NOW FOR 90
YEARS.
NOBODY REMEMBERS WHAT IT WAS
LIKE WHEN THERE WAS ANYTHING
OTHER THAN A ONE-PARTY STATE
RUNNING THESE APPALLING CITIES.
>> I THINK IT'S PERFECTLY
APPROPRIATE TO TALK ABOUT
POLITICS ON THE DAY IN A FEW
DAYS SURROUNDING THE ORIGINATION
OF THIS COUNTRY WHICH WAS AN
EXTREMELY POLITICAL ACT,
OBVIOUSLY AND THIS IS ABOUT
KEEPING IN MIND WHAT THE
FOUNDERS WANTED AND REPRESENTING
THEM WHICH MEANS BELIEVING THAT
EVERY SINGLE AMERICAN NO MATTER
WHAT CITY THEY LIVE IN DESERVES
TO BE ABLE TO HAVE A FUTURE
WHICH IS WHAT THE ENTIRE
REVOLUTION WAS ABOUT,
DETERMINING THEIR OWN FUTURES
AND NOW THAT WE'VE GOT IS A
POLITICAL SYSTEM DRIVEN BY
DEMOCRATS THAT HAVE DENIED THAT
FUTURE TO CHILDREN, TO BABIES,
TWO YOUNG PEOPLE EFFECTIVELY
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN CORRALLED
INTO THE URBAN AREAS AND ARE
CONTROLLED BY SINGLE PARTY.
THAT IS THE ANTITHESIS OF WHAT
THE REVOLUTION WANTED AND WHAT
IT WAS MEANT FOR, WHAT THE
FOUNDERS WANTED AND MAY I SAY
FOR EVERYONE ELSE WHO WAS AN
ANTIVIOLENCE ENTREPRENEUR,
SOMEONE WHO CAN MOVE INTO THOSE
CITIES AND UNDERSTANDS THEIR
COMMUNITY, THE FACT IS,
GOVERNMENTS AND POLITICIANS LIKE
LORI LIGHTFOOT NOW RELY ON FEAR.
THIS IS ABOUT -- VIOLENCE IS A
FACTOR OF THAT BUT VIOLENCE
CREATES FEAR THAT KEEPS PEOPLE
IN RETREAT AND IT SUITS THEM AND
YOU KNOW THIS WHEN SHE BLAMES
RACISM AND SEXISM, WHEN IT'S ALL
ABOUT HER, WHEN IT'S ABOUT THOSE
PEOPLE WHO ARE SUFFERING EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND THAT GREAT
AMERICAN CITY AND HIS SHAME ON
HER AND EVERYONE IN THE DEMOCRAT
PARTY WHO IS FACILITATING THIS.
>> Mark: I DON'T KNOW HOW THE
FAMILIES OF THOSE TWO LITTLE
GIRLS FIGHTING FOR THEIR LIVES
IN HOSPITALS AREN'T ENTIRELY
SICK AND INSULTED BY HER
REACHING FOR THOSE LAME TROPES.
THE LEFT TALK ABOUT OTHER ALL
THE TIME, I AM OTHER RING
TRANSGENDER'S, BUT THERE IS
NOTHING BASIC IN TERMS OF
OTHERIZING THAT YOU OPEN FIRE
AND YOU DON'T CARE WHETHER YOU
KILL KIDS?
ONCE YOU WERE AT THAT STAGE, HOW
DO THESE GUYS -- IT'S NOTHING
POLITICAL.
HOW DO YOU GET PULLED BACK FROM
THAT?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY THE NATURE OF
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN THERE WERE NO
REPERCUSSIONS.
AND IT'S NOT EVEN PASSIVITY,
IT'S A DECISION TO SIT BACK AND
ALLOW THAT AND WHEN YOU RECEIVE
SUBCONSCIOUSLY THE MESSAGE THAT
NO ONE IS GOING TO CARE FOR NO
ONE IS GOING TO COME AND STOP
ME, IT DOES SEND A SIGNAL ABOUT
WHAT'S APPROPRIATE IN A
COMMUNITY AND IF YOU WANT RACISM
AND SEXISM FOR LORI LIGHTFOOT
WHO GOD FORBID RAN AS A
REFORMER, I THOUGHT SHE MIGHT BE
THE PERSON TO DO THIS AND AS A
GAY WOMAN ON TOP OF IT TO BE IN
THE CITY THAT IS A RIVER OF
BLOOD AND ALL SHE CAN DO IS TALK
ABOUT OTHERIZING AS SHE GOES
HOME TO HER WHITE PARTNER, SHE
CREATES THIS AS A RACE
FRAMEWORK.
IT WHEN YOU ARE DEAD, THE COLOR
OF YOUR SKIN IS MEANINGLESS.
YOUR CHILDREN, YOUR
CONSTITUENTS, CITIZENS, ALL OF
THIS HAS GOT TO STOP BUT IT'S
PEOPLE LIKE LORI LIGHTFOOT AND
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WHO HAVE A
GHOULISH INTEREST IN FEAR AND
VIOLENCE AS A MECHANISM OF THAT.
>> Mark: THANK YOU FOR THAT,
TAMMY A